as we are closing in on a final count
we can begin to look toward our next
steps
with a margin that small there will be a
recount
in georgia interest in our election
obviously goes far beyond georgia's
borders
the final tally in georgia at this point
has huge
implications for the entire country
the stakes are high and emotions are
high
on all sides we will not let those
debates
distract us from our work we will get it
right
and we'll defend the integrity of our
elections
in some states there are complaints
about monitors
not being allowed to watch the count
in georgia this process is and will
remain open
and transparent to monitors if any
member of the public raises legitimate
concerns
we'll investigate those we are committed
to doing anything and everything
to maintaining trust in our elections
process
for every georgian regardless of
partisan preference
thank you very much mr dr secretary will
you take any questions
okay well there we have it uh 5 500
votes left to be counted
uh 8 890 military ballots still
to come in we heard him there saying as
if we didn't already know
the stakes are high but also the
emotions
are very high as well um the the process
uh is going to be uh monitored
throughout obviously back to georgia for
some more information there secretary
just announced a particular set of
numbers that actually went
down from the time we walked from the
door to here so our new total
that we are aware of right now is 4169
and they are in a handful of counties
i'll go over those now
in cherokee county there are 150 ballots
that they
did not upload so to rescan they're
uploading those today
there's 75 now in cobb there's 444 in
floyd
there's approximately 3 500 in gwinnett
as we went through the reconciliation
process
of what they had already reported versus
what they had left to newly scan
and i think that's it a couple of things
lawrence county the 1769 votes we had
yesterday we were basing those on the
absentee ballot differences
and when they looked and did their
reconciliation process on it
they discovered that they had
accidentally uh
uploaded those into their election day
totals their totals will not change
but the vote type will change when they
make that change today
so outside of that we don't have any
other numbers that we are aware of but
again i want to remind everybody
we have ballot curing processes through
today for absentee ballots
verification process for provisional
ballots
and we can still get any military or you
acaba ballots in
by close of business today if they were
postmarked on tuesday election day
so there are still an unknowable amount
of ballots that would be available to be
counted at some point they are in the
hands of the um uh elections officials
now other than maybe the military and
yuakawa ones
and i can assure you that there are
teams of 20-somethings around the state
who are republicans and democrats
finding those people with those absentee
ballots to cure
and they're going through that process
in county by county and ones and twos
and just a preemptive question i know
it's going to come up are we seeing any
widespread fraud are we seeing anything
that makes us question the outcome of
the election
we're not seeing widespread
irregularities we're not seeing anything
widespread
we are investigating any credible
accusation with any real evidence behind
it but let me tell you one thing
when you have a narrow margin little
small
things can make a difference so
everything's gonna have to be
investigated to protect the integrity of
the vote
our office intends to do that and like i
said
you get a wide margin it doesn't matter
as much narrow margin it does we are
literally looking at a margin of less
than you know a large high school
so we understand that in the state the
county officials are aware of that our
investigators are aware of that
so it's an important thing to protect
the integrity of this election
from all sides